oh so you happened to look up the to to
register big con yeah let's confirm that
yeah I got it right
vidcon.com right now we are 12 12 20 22.
so this was this was registered stop
VidCon was registered before he
announced he was leaving the blaze is
that what it was that's so weird he
announced he was leaving The Blaze on
12th well guys and again Crowder will be
here on Monday he can tell tell us about
all this I don't know and then he
recorded his conversation with Jeremy
two months after that I just want to say
like we're we're we're we're we're in
the middle as per usual Candace was
booked a month and a half ago you know
and this whole drama lights up and then
uh we talked with Crowder uh he we we
asked him to come on and talk about this
so I mean there are so many things that
I disagree with daily wire on like so
many things this is just not one of them
like this is just actually someone's
being a bad person and plotting against
them that's it that's all that's all
this is right